hello hey I mean congratulations on all
the awards thank you yeah I mean
everybody hasn't even seen it yet and
like you're already winning awards that
has to feel pretty fantastic oh it's
pretty cool it's pretty
cool yeah so okay so you're you play a
very even from that scene you can kind
of tell very complex character it's kind
of this childhood has been taken away
but you also have this Awakening going
on as well as an adult yes how hard was
that to play ah I mean it it was a lot
of work but Samy script it was there's
so much in between the text so I really
just dove into it and looked at certain
parts of my life I know did you relate
it all kind of a little bit you know cuz
you know Joe he at such a young age he
was a father so it was like this immense
sense of uh responsibility and I grew up
an army brat oh your dad was at house so
my dad was in the Army and he served a
few years in uh in the war so I remember
him sitting me down when I was 11 and he
just gave me this inspirational talk
about being a leader and honor and
integrity
and like taking care of my two younger
sisters and my mom so he's my he's my
hero so when he told me that I kind of
stepped up to the plate while he was
away and
yeah uh feeling is maybe similar but
different experience yeah just having to
grow up a little quicker in a different
way yes yeah I think a lot of us we go
through that in different family
situations so yeah that could be
relatable but I heard that you also you
had to eat was it fast food that you ate
a lot of to gain weight for the role
yeah I mean I didn't have to eat it I
kind
of it they were like you should get away
for the r and you like ran to all the
fast food no it you know to Todd Haynes
our director we had conversations about
what Joe would feel like yeah not so
much look like and I was like I think
this may be my
opportunity yeah he's a 36y old dad
three kids yeah provider all this stuff
like he doesn't have time to go to the
gym but maybe he has time to eat yeah
this is my moment to eat whatever I want
so I ate so much uh pizza fast food ice
cream nicely done yeah I heard well I
heard this is not your first experience
with fast food you actually worked fast
food whenever you were younger right I
did okay where did you work so my first
place was Arby's Classic Roast Beef oh
amazing they used to they they used to
have like the five with sauce yes they
used to have like the five for five for
like 5.95 or something dude I know yeah
it was amazing yeah so I was so I was
there for 6 months yeah right after 6
months you know I came home I told my
dad dad I've learned so much from just
you know life behind the counter and I
I'm ready to to move forward I'm just
ready to move forward and you know I I
thank you I'm going to just focus in
school and everything thank you for this
opportunity thank you yeah I'm a
sophomore in high school like I'm ready
to just yeah thank you Dad and he gets a
phone call and he was like Hey I so your
boss told me you got
fired yeah you told him thank you for
the
opportunity and he was like what
happened and so me and one of my
co-workers after playing ice hockey with
brooms in the back as you do he threw a
curly fry and I ducked and it the curly
fry hit a customer in the face and wait
you got fired for that yeah I uh not
even like a do better next time no it
was so so so I turned in my notice and I
I love oh you did turn in your
notice I love you so much so wait before
before we go quickly share you have a
Wendy's hack I love your fast food
stories okay yes another fast food story
what is your Wendy's hack yeah so my
Wendy's hack because after the RBS my
dad's like we're going to
Wendy's
elevated uh so we go there and um yeah
so I love working the cash register and
there's so many substitutions you can do
so it's I can mix up I can get a
Baconator and substitute like the
pretzel bread or the jalapeno cheddar
bread or I can get you can do that you
can do that it's just like a matter of
how you
communicate the order you know how to
which I know and so they know how to
there's like no complications at all
they're just like oh my gosh thank you
yeah you're making this so easy it's a
dream client oh my gosh you're
great oh my God I love how different you
are from your role that you're playing
in this
movie you are a great actor you are so
different from this Ro it's amazing I
love you so much let's do another
commercial break everybody May December
which is amazing is now on Netflix you
got to check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home